what
initially attracted you to this script
the story
well craig this is a
uh one of a kind like aaron brockovich
a dramatic piece of work that really
gets you inside of a major problem
this got me inside of a problem and that
i knew nothing about
and i don't think very many people know
about the contamination of water
in the central valley of the farmland
where people are you know where we get
all of our food
i'd say about 70 percent of the produce
and stuff comes from
that valley and 80 percent of all the
almonds in the world
come from that valley um so
when i read about it and i said oh my
goodness what a story
i knew that one that it had to be told
and two that you had to be very
understanding how to tell the story
because the last thing
and this was in 2018 this is before the
pandemic hit
but people were really i mean the last
thing you need to do is to do another
erin brockovich
that's not yet the way to handle uh uh
the realities of what we're facing today
because
it just it's overwhelming i mean and
imagine we're coming out in october
during the height of the pandemic the
last thing people want to see is a movie
that depresses them
that's not the idea and and therefore
back in 2018 i said you know
i don't think but now it's even worse so
but my timing
our timing was excellent because it's
it's a buddy movie
uh fred stern played by david strathearn
myself playing santiago
he's the landowner and i'm his manager
of his farm
and and this is all truth fred stern is
a real person
and santiago is a real person and
they're living and well
fred stern passed away about i'd say 10
months ago
but santiago is still working there
and it's a story that brings you into a
body story a familial
bond between two men that work together
and have for 30 years
and uh it at the same time it unleashes
and evolves into telling you a story
uh about the contamination done by the
old companies
and it tells you a lot about the uh the
net present
value of life and we get into it very
strongly net present value meaning
if it costs you less
than what you're making doing it
continue doing it now think about what i
just said
in the oil companies in the any company
anywhere that's making more money than
it costs them to
to work if somebody sues you for the
problem
continue doing it that's there's
actually a saying when i learned that
saying i said
oh my god this is crazy i never heard of
this
and so sure enough and it's it's in the
movie and marty sheen who plays the
attorney
does a brilliant job boy he does a
really good job of understanding
and he makes a very very strong
understanding for all the audience to
see
absolutely um it is a very scary thought
to have to communicate
but it's not a depressing film at times
it's really
kind of darkly savagely funny and i'm
curious
what was it like good words great thank
you
what was it like kind of walking this
tonal tightrope how did you figure out
when to be funny when to be more serious
when to be even like sort of suspense
driven
i think it took on its own truth if you
stayed with the facts you know if you
stayed
in my aesthetic i always put the camera
with the story is so
if you stayed with the story you
understood it and it became funny when
it was supposed to be funny and they
became very understanding when it was
supposed to be
and uh that's the outlay of the story we
worked on the script a lot
and rob uh macabee who
this was his first script ever and he's
about 26 27 year old
and uh this is his first time uh first
produced script
and so he uh him and i worked together
many many hours and for many many days
and
when we got to the set we actually
continued to work on the script
and so it was something that really
evolved and i will say that
the relationship between santiago and
fred is the key to the whole movie
and and it you start to feel it from the
beginning
and then you really feel it as as it
gets intensifies
the only time you get a break from that
dramatic intensity of the truth is when
santiago and fred get together and then
you see
and feel the the the uh you know
[Music]
the truth of the situation and the
friendship and the love
and the respect that they have for one
another which then permeates itself
inside of the story which is very very
difficult that's a difficult story greg
i mean people are not going to believe
it but in 2020 right now
october uh that water that is
contaminated by the oil
companies you got to understand one
thing when when
the oil companies take out one barrel of
oil
from the ground 15 barrels of water
comes out with it
so what do you do with the water
that comes out okay that's the essence
of the story
and i don't want to get give anything
away but the devil has a name
which opens uh october 16th on
uh pay-per-view uh all over the country
and it's gonna be on
theaters too i mean how many theaters
could be open maybe four
but you know you'll be able to see it in
theater and in
on pay-per-view but pay-per-view is
probably how almost everything's being
seen right now yeah these days
especially um
so santiago and fred's relationship
their loving relationship
kind of erupts in one key scene when
they
they fight each other they wrestle each
other and it sort of evolves into
laughter what was it like
staging this kind of peculiar scene well
yeah
i tell you everybody was was waiting to
see how i was gonna do it and
uh including the actor and david and
myself and i said this is gonna be very
easy david
uh we're just gonna go for it because
what do you mean
i go i'm gonna jam you like this and i
said okay ready did you read ray
rayviolos with his cameras and he's
handheld cameras i used two cameras
uh at the same time so we could capture
different angles but in close-ups
everything was
we worked when i work him with my when
i'm working
i i kind of go for the meet
i go for the main shots first
so i'm in tight from the beginning so
that all the realities
are caught and it's not like i start way
far
outside and then start working my way
inside into the picture like many many
people do
i start on the inside and i capture it
until i got it and then once i got it
then i stepped back and i know and i
open it up from there
but uh so yeah we we got into it and i
said okay
this is what i'm gonna do to you you're
rolling right you gotta go
okay here we go this is what we're gonna
do
[Music]
we went down he goes everyone and then
we rolled on the
you know you saw it i mean we were all
on the table and we got to the end and
he's pulling i'm
i had my hand well i had my hand in his
face he had his head
in my face and you know what what
happens during that period of time and
it was just hysterical
and we were dying real laughter i mean
the crew
had to like stop from laughing out loud
because it would have ruined the shot
and it was it was beautifully i i must
say to david
strathearn who's a brilliant artist a
brilliant actor
um he deserves the accolades that he's
received in his lifetime
uh he made it really easy man he went
with it and man we
we went we did it that's how we did it
there was no okay we're gonna rehearse
the tumble scene again they're ready
let's go no because i mean you do it you
have to really
do it you know so if we're gonna
practice it we're gonna really do it so
why not shoot it
you know if we're gonna do it and we're
gonna practice it
shoot the practice shoot the rehearsal
yeah so that's what we did
um speaking of your aesthetic style or
your style as a director
what is it like working simultaneously
as a director and a leading actor how do
you
direct yourself so to speak well there's
where
um you have to have a team
your team is everything and your team
consists of your sound department
your cinematography department your
wardrobe department all the different
heads
have to be understanding of the
situation to help you get to that point
the you know the set designer everybody
has to be working in
harmony in unison because basically if
you're not if they're not
if i have to really pinpoint every
single little aspect of it
i couldn't do it it'd be overwhelming so
i i get people that i've worked with
before
ray had done quite a few films with
rabia lowe's the cinematographer
he did some brilliant he's done
brilliant work and continues to do that
even today
and he's in his 80s now and
i will say that he he and i worked
together
very very well we were constantly in
each other's ear
and um so it was really
it was understanding and allowing
growth around you and that takes the
security
security within myself to trust
and i trust the people that are working
with so
in my sound department i said did you
get it yeah okay
they got it okay i'm not listening to
the sound when
it's happening and it's oh i heard
something wait a minute or you know like
other people are watching it on on the
monitor and say wait a minute oh you see
how that happened
we got to do that over again and do this
okay i can't do that
so what we do is that we do the scene
and then we do have playback
and immediately after the scene is done
i go to the machines that i do quickly
because
it takes up too much time if you don't
really know what you're doing
and so you're eating you twice you've
seen
the scene that you're doing not only do
you do it and then you have to see it
again so that
that that time you need with only six
weeks of
time to shoot the movie you have to do
everything
succinctly so basically that's what we
did i would watch the thing and say okay
let's do it one more time
this time ray pull yourself around a
little bit more make sure that you grab
the you know
this and this and do whatever and then
you know but he was way ahead of me and
he was getting stuff i'd say man ray
that was beautiful
thank you ray you made me look great
uh one thing i really love about your
character santiago
we only get like little hints of it his
sort of
revolutionary even anarchist
leaning politics what uh how would you
describe his political leanings and how
much of that is personal to you
well no i it was him i mean santiago is
a real person
and yeah he really is a
a person who is um uh you know
he believes in in um
[Music]
fred stern played by david strathard
uh is the owner of the
of the uh farm but santiago really runs
it i mean he's for 30 years he is
really the person who produces
everything that's done on the farm
even though fred knows what he's doing
and and
you know participates in the
understanding and they work together to
produce
all the almonds that they produce and 80
of all the almonds in the world come
from that region and that it's a huge
farm that they have
and so he is uh uh very
very anarchistic he doesn't believe in
outside
governing of the inside situation which
is what
anarchism really is at a whole they
don't believe in
having uh you know washington dc tell
you know bakersfield how to live you
know
so you know that's just his format and
his understanding so
and that perspective i i i found it to
be hysterical because
fred uh he throws it in his face as many
times as he possibly can you know
and i thought it was just perfect i
loved it
because uh you know santiago doesn't
care
call me anything you want to call me i
don't care i'm gonna have my ideals and
you have yours and too much you know
good luck
and so he was pretty constantly
constantly fighting
each other and it made for great humor
and inside of a story like this it's
really needed
i mean the last thing you want to do is
put every anybody through an erin
brockovich right now
i mean forget it man i just that isn't
uh
[Music]
enough reality already okay we get
nightly news
fake news has it going everywhere so
don't worry about a thing right
so basically i think it it the timing
for this movie
and what it's saying and people
understanding and digesting it
couldn't be better and um i think people
are going to be very interested i think
they're going to do
their research and find out as much as
they can about the situation because
it's their food chain
yeah i couldn't agree more that's all
the time i have thanks so much edward
great talking with you
thank you very much greg thank you so
much for your
you know your interest in bringing this
to the pub people